Selling the right to broadcast a television
or radio program to independent stations,
syndication has enabled the modern system
of 24/7 broadcasting by providing producers
of content with a consistent revenue stream,
and stations with enough programming to satisfy
their eager audiences.
There are a variety of syndication types,
including movie packages and public broadcasting,
although perhaps the two most common, and
lucrative, are first-run and off-network (re-runs).
First-run syndication refers to shows that
have never been aired previously and common
examples today include Wheel of Fortune and
Judge Judy.
Off-network syndication refers to shows that
were first aired on network television, and
are being broadcast again (aka: re-run); common
examples today include The Big Bang Theory
and Modern Family.
Note that when these programs were first aired
by the networks, they were shown through either
stations that were owned-and-operated by the
network (O&O) or network affiliates, with
which the network has a special contractual
agreement that covers programming as well
as other issues.
So how did this system get setup?
Syndication of entertainment programs has
been around since the 1930s, when syndicated
radio shows were being distributed throughout
the United States.
These first radio programs were distributed
on transcription disks (similar to old LPs,
but with higher audio quality for broadcast).
This format was eventually replaced by phonograph
records, then tape recordings, cassettes and
CDs, and while the practice of buying and
selling radio shows is ongoing, today they
are likely to be downloaded.
In any event, early popular syndicated radio
shows included The Chevrolet Chronicles and
the wildly popular Amos ‘n’ Andy.
A cultural phenomenon at the start of the
Great Depression, the 15 minute show aired
six nights each week and boasted upwards of
40 million listeners.
Throughout the 1940s, syndicated radio shows
remained popular due in no small part to programs
such as The Adventures of Superman, which
ran through 1949.
(And if you’re curious about how Superman’s
curious underwear choices started, see: Why
Superheroes Wear Their Underwear on the Outside)
While televisions were made and some limited
television broadcasting was done in the late
1930s, large-scale, commercial broadcasting
didn’t appear in the United States until
the late 1940s.
Taking a page out of radio stations’ books,
independent televisions stations soon realized
they were desperate for additional programming
to fill the hours in between their original
productions.
Capitalizing on that need was Frederick Ziv,
who had cut his teeth in advertising in the
1930s, developing slogans for the burgeoning
radio market, including “The Freshest Thing
in Town,” for Cincinnati’s Rubel’s Bakery.
The ad campaign was so popular that Ziv was
able to transform it into a full-fledged,
15 minute, five-day each week radio program,
which he soon syndicated across the South
and Midwest.
Realizing he had found a new market, within
a decade Ziv had built a successful syndication
company, selling shows such as Favorite Story
and Bold Venture, this last starring Humphrey
Bogart and Lauren Bacall, to stations across
North America.
Jumping with both feet into the fledgling
television syndication market, Ziv’s first
television show, Fireside Theatre began airing
in 1949.
It was soon followed by others including Easy
Aces (1949-1950),The Cisco Kid (1950-1956),
I Led Three Lives (1953-1956) Highway Patrol
(1955-1959), Whirlybirds (1957-1960), Bat
Masterson (1958-1961) and Sea Hunt (1958-1961).
With such a large and early contribution to
syndication, it is no wonder Frederick Ziv
earned the moniker, the “father of syndicated
television.”
Over the years, syndication has become even
more popular, and lucrative, and those in
the highest demand in recent years include
NFL regular season games, The Big Bang Theory,
Modern Family, Judge Judy, Wheel of Fortune
and Jeopardy.
Between the two game shows alone they average
more than 22 million viewers daily which helps
to explain why they are among the longest-running
syndicated shows in history.
Another notable syndicated champion is Seinfeld.
Between 1998 and 2013, Seinfeld has generated
more than $3 billion in syndication fees,
and its co-creators, Larry David and Jerry
Seinfeld, themselves have each raked in as
much as $400 million from selling the show
as re-runs.
There appears no end in sight either; only
a few days ago, Hulu announced it had acquired
the online streaming rights for the show,
with a deal valued at around $1 million per
episode (a total of 180 episodes).
Note that programs that are still in first-run
can be syndicated as well once they reach
the 85-100 episode threshold; for example,
Modern Family recently went into syndication
on USA, costing the network $1.4 million per
episode.
Syndicating a current show can offer other
benefits as well.
After the popular show, The Big Bang Theory,
went into syndication, its audience for first
run episodes rose by 21%.